[Music]
if you're wondering why I've decided to
not come back it wasn't an easy decision
you know it's hard to walk away from
something that that first of all is
successful and you've been doing for
five years and truly has given us so
much but I just feel like right at this
particular point in time a couple of
things first of all you know my kids are
my oldest kids are now teenagers and I
just felt like they need to make their
own decision about being on television
and exposing their lives and for me
personally I have some really cool
interesting opportunities going on right
now that I want to explore you know I
don't know where they're gonna go but I
want the opportunity to explore them and
I felt like I was at a tipping point and
it was just it was time but I think it's
all positive and and I wish them all the
best this turned me into a more of an
adventurous person oh yeah I mean who
ever thought I would like whitewater
rafting ziplining surfing Glamis which
I'm never doing that again thank you
very much but I mean so many cool
experience experiences and adventures
and and really like a different world
opened up for me and my family so I'm
really so grateful about it and I will
miss the girls